[Music]
some superheroes can grow to the size of
a building at will
that's very intimidating but a scientist
must ask where the extra material is
coming from
the law of conservation of mass implies
that mass can neither be created nor
destroyed which means that our hero's
mass will not change just because his
size changes
for instance when we bake a fluffy
sponge cake
even though the resulting delicious
treat is much bigger in size than the
cake batter that went into the oven the
weight of the cake batter should still
equal the weight of the cake plus the
moisture that has evaporated
in a chemical equation molecules
rearrange to make new compounds but all
the components should still be accounted
for when our hero expands from six feet
tall to 18 feet tall his height
triples galileo's square cube law says
his weight will be 27 3 times 3 times 3
equals 27 times his regular weight since
he has to expand in all three dimensions
so when our superhero transforms into a
giant we are dealing with two
possibilities our hero towering at 18
feet still only weighs 200 pounds the
original weight in his human form
now option two our hero weighs 5
400 pounds 200 pounds times 27 equals 5
400 pounds when he is 18 feet tall which
means he also weighs
5 400 pounds
when he is six feet tall
nobody can get in the same elevator with
him without the alarm going off now
option two seems a little more
scientifically plausible but it begs the
question how does he ever walk through
the park without sinking into the ground
since the pressure he is exerting on the
soil is calculated by his mass divided
by the area of the bottom of his feet
and what kind of super socks and super
shoes is he putting on his feet to
withstand all the friction that results
from dragging his fifty four hundred
pound body against the road when he runs
oh
and can he even run and i won't even ask
how he finds pants flexible enough to
withstand the expansion
whoa
look out
now let's explore the density of the two
options mentioned above
density is defined as mass divided by
volume the human body is made out of
bones and flesh which has a relatively
set density in option 1 if the hero
weighs 200 pounds all the time then he
would be bones and flesh at normal size
when he expands to a bigger size while
still weighing 200 pounds he essentially
turns himself into a giant fluffy teddy
bear
in option 2 if the hero weighs 5 400
pounds all the time then he would be
bones and flesh at 18 feet with 5 400
pounds of weight supported by two legs
the weight will be exerted on the leg
bones at different angles as he moves
bones while hard are not malleable
meaning they do not bend so they break
easily
the tendons would also be at risk of
tearing tall buildings stay standing
because they have steel frames and do
not run and jump around in the jungle
our hero on the other hand one landing
at a bad angle
and he's down
assuming his bodily function is the same
as any mammals his heart would need to
pump a large amount of blood throughout
his body to provide enough oxygen for
him to move 5400 pounds of body weight
around this would take tremendous energy
which he would need to provide by
consuming 27 times 3 000 calories of
food every day now that is roughly 150
big macs
27 times 3 000 calculated equals 81 000
calculated 550 calories equals 147. he
wouldn't have time to fight crime
because he would be eating all the time
and working a nine-to-five job in order
to afford all the food he eats
and what about superheroes who can turn
their bodies into rocks or sand well
everything on earth is made out of
elements and what defines each element
is the number of protons in the nucleus
that is how our periodic table is
organized hydrogen has one proton helium
two protons lithium three protons and so
on the primary component of the most
common form of sand is silicon dioxide
meanwhile the human body consists of 65
oxygen 18 carbon 10 hydrogen and 7
percent of various other elements
including
0.002 percent of silicon
in a chemical reaction the elements
recombine to make new compounds so where
is he getting all the silicon necessary
to make the sand
sure we can alter elements by nuclear
fusion or nuclear fission however
nuclear fusion requires so much heat the
only natural occurrence of this process
is in stars
in order to utilize fusion in a short
amount of time the temperature of the
area needs to be hotter than the sun
every innocent bystander will be burned
to a crisp
rapid nuclear fission is not any better
since it often results in many
radioactive particles our hero would
become a walking talking nuclear power
plant ultimately harming every person he
tries to save
and do you really want the heat of the
sun or a radioactive nuclear plant
inside of your body
that burns
now which superpower physics lesson will
you explore next
shifting body size and content
super speed
flight
super strength
immortality
and
invisibility
you